all to embrace change and build a
national pact by a president struggling
to advance his transformative agenda
Colombia's first ever left his president
Gustavo Petro gave his first speech to a
joint session of Congress on Colombia's
Independence Day
many here consider this a Do or Die
moment for the government's many
ambitious reforms
there is a window of opportunity it is
the time for social reforms it's the
moment and it can't be done in a day in
which this country can become more
egalitarian and that's why it's the
moment for a national Pact
the president defiantly presented his
vision of Colombia at a time when
climate change represents a
life-threatening risk to humanity once
again promising to move the country away
from its Reliance on oil and coal and
towards a sustainable energy transition
it's not just about making speeches it's
about trying to advance in environmental
and social justice the answer has been
ambivalent we have encountered a
struggle there are forces in society and
the state that oppose it
he also called on lawmakers to pass
Health labor pension education and
agricultural reforms that he believes
can profoundly change a country that
remains among the most socially and
economically unequal in the world but
those reforms face an uphill battle the
broad Coalition the president had built
in Congress when he first took office
has fallen apart as traditional parties
find the president's proposals to
radical and his style overbearing
I think the government needs to do more
to negotiate the reforms if he doesn't
become more conciliatory trying to pass
these reforms will be an ordeal he can't
expect Congress to be a notary of what
he wants
your position booed the president
showing banners of dead soldiers when
Petra said that his policy of
negotiating deals and ceasefires with
armed groups and mafias reduce the debts
of soldiers and policemen by 55 or 60
percent
and since losing the elections the
opposition has managed to regroup and
mobilize large protests against the
reforms
we have said repeatedly that the
president is not listening to those who
think differently from him but our
opposition is interested in building not
doing damage
Victory a year ago was a watershed
moment for Colombia's left his politics
yes transforming his promises into
tangible change remains elusive